how do you explain when others are able
to achieve things that seem to defy all
of the assumptions why is Apple so
Innovative year after year after year
after year they're more Innovative than
all their competition and yet they're
just a computer company they're just
like everyone else they have the same
access to the same Talent the same
agencies the same Consultants the same
media then why is it that they seem to
have something different why is it that
Martin Luther King led the Civil Rights
Movement
he wasn't the only man who suffered in a
pre-civil rights America and he
certainly wasn't the only great orator
of the day why him and why is it that
the Wright brothers were able to figure
out controlled powered man flight when
there were certainly other teams who
were better qualified better funded and
they didn't achieve
powered man flight the Wright brothers
beat them to it there's something else
at play here about three and a half
years ago I made a discovery
and this discovery profoundly changed my
view on how I thought the world worked
and it even profoundly changed the way
in which I operated it as it turns out
there's a pattern as it turns out all
the great and inspiring leaders and
organizations in the world whether it's
apple or Martin Luther King or the
Wright brothers they all think act and
communicate the exact same way
and it's the complete opposite to
everyone else all I did was codify it
and it's probably the world's simplest
idea I call it the Golden Circle
why how what this little idea explains
why some organizations and some leaders
are able to inspire where others aren't
let me Define the terms really quickly
every single person every single
organization on the planet knows what
they do 100 some know how they do it
when you call it your differentiating
value proposition or your proprietary
process or your USP but very very few
people or organizations know why they do
what they do and by why I don't mean to
make a profit that's a result it's
always a result by why I mean what's
your purpose what's your cause what's
your belief
the human brain cannot comprehend the
negative
it is incapable I'll give you an example
don't think of an elephant
uh
can I tell the human brain not to do
something and so what happens is we very
often reinforce things when we put
things in the negative I can't get a
part or I can't do this versus I'm going
to keep doing this I'm going to keep
doing this it's such a huge thing to
convert things into the affirmative
you're supposed to do with children as
well instead of saying to children don't
eat on the couch we're supposed to say
eat at the table right we tell people
what we want them to do not want them
what we don't want to do pilots know
this it is well known in the pilot
community that when you tell a pilot
don't hit the obstacle they'll hit the
obstacle because what they're doing is
focusing on the obstacle
skiers know this
if if you ever seen skiers go through
trees it's very easy it's actually
surprisingly easy if you go through
trees on skis you go don't hit a tree
don't hit a tree don't hit a tree guess
what you're watching you're only looking
at trees
all you're doing is seeing trees you
don't understand how anyone can ski with
all these trees as opposed to follow the
snow follow the path follow the path the
only thing you see is the path
skiers know this if you say don't hit a
tree you'll hit a tree you won't be able
to find a path because all you see is
millions of trees if you say only follow
the path you actually don't see any
trees there's actually very sparse trees
there's plenty of path there's plenty of
snow
it's the same thing for you if you focus
on the obstacles all you will see is
obstacles if you focus on the path
through the trees
all you will see is path through the
trees
it's your choice how you choose to
perceive your own career it's literally
perspective I don't think you can
motivate the unmotivated I don't think
you could motivate people people either
are motivated or unmotivated I think you
can inspire people you can motivate
people with sticks and carrots you know
offer them Bounty or threatened
punishment and you'll get behavior that
you want
is there loyalty is their love
absolutely not usually when people are
unmotivated it's not necessarily them it
might be the situation they're in maybe
they don't belong in the culture maybe
they feel unseen or unheard maybe
they're scared maybe they're unprepared
when somebody's unmotivated let's not
label them as unmotivated first what are
the 20 other things that it could also
be let's start there
when I was writing leaders At Last I got
to the point where I couldn't do it it
was too difficult I couldn't organize
all the information it was just too
complicated I I couldn't do it and I've
been trying for months I probably missed
multiple deadlines and I was sitting at
my computer and I decided that I had to
give up I couldn't do it
and so I got up and went for a walk and
I was literally planning my exit I was
going through the steps I was going
through the checklist of quitting I knew
that I have to give my Advance back to
the publisher because technically I'm in
breach I knew that I would be humiliated
but I Was preparing myself for it and
that I would get over it I was also
rationalizing that it was okay to quit I
told myself there were thousands ten
thousand books published every single
year no one will miss this one book
and I literally went through the steps
to prepare myself
for what I had to do to quit
I'm not sure why I did this but I called
a friend of mine who at the time was in
the Air Force Special Forces and I don't
even think I said hello when he picked
up the phone I simply asked the question
what do you do when you can't complete
the mission and as is his habit he just
started telling me a story
he was a helicopter pilot
and they had a mission in Afghanistan
that was a suicide mission all the
intelligence showed that the area
defenses were just too great and none of
them were going to come out alive and it
wasn't going to be one of those kill
Hitler missions where we're all going to
die but we'll kill Hitler this is like
we're all gonna die and the mission will
also fail and he was preparing his
helicopter
for this Mission and his wingman turned
him and said
what do we do
we've got wives we've got kids do we
refuse to go what do we do
and my friend turned to him and they
said this is what we signed up for
we go
he asked me he said is this book more or
less powerful
than
start with why I said the research has
impacted Me Greater it's more powerful
he says all right I'm going to tell you
a funny story before I met you I'd
become disillusion with the Air Force
and I was going to quit and I found this
cookie little book called start with why
and it completely reinspired me
and I decided to stay and I'm a better
leader now than I was before because of
that book and if you're saying that this
book is more powerful than the first one
then we need this book he said this is
what you signed up for you have no
choice
clearly our lives are finite we're born
we die we come we go
but life is infinite
The Game of Life will continue with us
or without us which means every single
one of us has a choice we don't get to
choose the nature of the game Life is
infinite we don't even get to choose if
we want to play in the game or night
once you're born you're in it we get one
choice
do you want to play with a finite
mindset
or do you want to play with an infinite
play with a finite mindset means waking
up every day and say I'm going to be the
best I'm going to be better than
everybody else
I'm going to accumulate more power more
responsibility more money whatever it is
whatever whatever your metric is
I'm gonna I'm gonna get more than
anybody else me and when you die
you take none of it with you
or we can choose to live our lives with
an infinite mindset which means I'm
going to leave this world the school in
better shape than I found it it means
I'm going to devote my life to see that
those around me rise and we know that
we're living with an infinite mindset
because our obsession is seeing that we
have an impact on the lives of the
people around us we've all had teachers
and some of you are those teachers we're
20 or 30 years from now I can go to one
of your students and say you're a
remarkable human being you've
accomplished so much in your life how
did you become the person you are today
and they will tell me your name we all
remember the teacher who believed in us
we all remember the teacher who had our
backs we all remember the teachers saw
something in us that nobody else saw
we've forgotten all the others but we
remember those couple and that's what it
means to live with an infinite mindset
it means we divert ourselves to that
mindset for everyone in our lives that
other teachers will say that about us
other principles will say that about us
other students will say that about us
our friends will say that about us I am
who I am today because of you and I will
commit to live the same life that you
taught me how to live and you will
literally live on beyond your own
lifestyle your own lifetime that when
you're gone others will carry your work
for you
this is what it means to live an
infinite life and it is just
a choice